all right Thursday November 3rd is
National men make dinner day and if
you're like me and don't cook too often
we have someone to help it's Chef Bruce
from Seoul Billy good to see you buddy
you too man uh Soul Billy barbecue is
where you're from yeah there's a
misconception to you like chefs don't
really cook at home you never cook in
the house well because I'm always at
work but you know how to cook yeah I
have an idea I know what you're doing I
don't for someone like me and guys out
there that don't know what they're doing
for sure where do you start okay so
everybody loves a burrito right sure a
burrito is a great item if you've got
like leftovers in the fridge and all
that kind of stuff and if you don't have
leftovers go to the store yeah buy some
of your favorite ingredients because
it's a great way to like clean out your
fridge quite honestly because I open my
fridge there's nothing in there okay so
you get the recipe you want make sure
you get everything on the recipe go to
the store buy your ingredients yeah
exactly so like if you want let's say a
burrito go online Google you know
chicken burrito and you'll see all kinds
of recipes come up and formulas and and
everything so like I I went through our
cooler and this is like Love Don't over
so like when we you know we smoke our
chicken legs we don't reheat them for
service what we'll do is we'll pull the
meat and then use it for a burrito or
nachos or something like that so I've
got some of our beautiful smoked you
know spice chicken here is there like a
hack because I don't want a time to cook
the chicken am I buying pre-cooked
chicken maybe yeah you can buy
pre-cooked chicken you know otherwise I
mean get like insta pots all the ninja
products are awesome the fry air fryer
yes is amazing better a bigger one or a
smaller one I mean if you're just
cooking for yourself get a small one
yeah and then these are just like you
know we do a load of baked potatoes so
we have leftover potatoes we cut them
and make fries or we'll cut them and do
like breakfast potatoes like this you
just get creative with what you have is
what you're doing here yeah I mean just
think about all the things that you love
to eat right hey we're about a minute
left here I do want to touch on
something keep on cooking keep on making
but this past Saturday was the big when
you were young Festival yeah canceled
because of wind you guys stepped up an
All-American Rejects came down to your
restaurant yep and performed there on
Saturday night before the show how was
that online it looked like insanity we
see the guys here on camera before the
Big Show how was it Saturday it was
absolute insanity and then our
performance organized I I'm no uh no Pro
like concert event organizer I can
organize events but nothing like this I
mean there was over a thousand people in
line all the way around the restaurant
two alleys down and you know we did the
best we could to kind of contain
everything the restaurant was packed all
day well you guys stepped up you really
stepped up for Las Vegas and you always
step up with your food too if someone's
watching and they don't want to cook on
National men cook day where do we find
you guys uh we're at Soul belly uh
barbecue 1327 South Main in the arts
district I love it Bruce thank you so
much I'm gonna eat this during break and
Las Vegas now we